[Music]
hello everyone my name is Elsie Kenyon
and I'm excited to be here today with my
colleagues from 2 Sigma now 2 Sigma is
an investment manager which applies data
science and technology to find value in
the world's financial markets so why you
may ask are we here today to talk about
games well in two Sigma's 17-year
cultural history there have been many
successful internal challenges organized
around games you may have seen a YouTube
video of our air hockey robot
competition we found that these games in
particularly games that pare humans with
machines are really unique opportunities
for applying new skills to difficult
challenges two years ago two Sigma
interns Ben and Michael here today
created an entirely new such game halite
in which players play build BOTS that
play the games for them the halite
artificial intelligence competition was
so successful within two sigma that we
opened up the competition globally
Orban's open source the code base and
repeated the process the next year with
a brand new game this fall will launch
the third annual halite artificial
intelligence competition now today there
have been thousands of players from over
100 countries that have played halite
these players submitted BOTS have been
written in over 20 different languages
and have played millions of games now on
the one hand a global programming
competition has provided two sigma with
a new source for identifying strong
talent but there's another stronger
promise
a light at the top of this halite -
leaderboard you'll see professionals
university students and even a high
school student at number four we've seen
players of all ages and experience
levels engaged with advanced algorithms
AI and machine learning via this
immersive game on their own and with
each other
this is halite one the rules of the game
can be explained in a paragraph but the
branching factor but the game has a
granting factor many times that of the
game of Go it's an open-ended
environment in which many strategies can
be successful this laboratory like
nature is a feature of halite which you
understand better as what you'll
understand further as Ben and Michael
contextualized halite in the history of
games and share the principles guiding
highlights development running halite
requires significant back-end resources
jack will explain how google cloud
enabled two sigma to run a global AI
competition at scale with no downtime we
consider a halite a game designed for
this era and AI and this era in
technology and we hope by the end of
today that you will - now I'll hand it
over to Michael and Ben thank you thanks
Lucy so ok so we're gonna talk a little
bit about the halite games the
predecessors the process the principles
and all that we want to start with an
introduction of sort of the evolution of
games and how halite fits into that that
history and as you know all
presentations need a cute picture of
cats to succeed here's ours but it also
has an actual meeting for the the
presentation to that I think we often
conceptualize of games sort of uniquely
human thing but they're not that we see
games with animals all the time here
these Cubs are sort of play wrestling so
that when they have to wrestle for real
later in life they'll be ready um we
think that this Lee
to an important use of games that really
games under one viewpoint under one lens
are about learning that a game is an
environment with you know very low risk
in which you can try new strategies and
ideas explore hone your skills so that
when it actually matters you'll be ready
and continuing on in that thread just a
little bit about some early strategy
games that stick around today there are
earlier games like you know Egyptian
games of sort of dice that perceived
these games but the ones that have
really remained popular are these game
strategies primarily go in chess which
originated about 2,500 years ago and
then just about a thousand years later
and what's key about these games is that
they're both you know in their time
they've both been considered these tools
for learning strategy that you know as a
military commander you'd be expected to
be good at chess in addition to a good
military trainer that was thought that
there's some transfer of the skill
between them but that also we see games
kind of come into their own as a form of
art and you know I think in we might
have this idea that games art is very
modern in that you know now we have all
sorts of video games that are artistic
and you know take you through some story
and all that but really this originates
a lot earlier with these games all right
so the history of games and machines is
definitely a lot shorter than that of
the history of humans playing games you
know it's about 50 years versus many
thousands of years but it is a dense
history nonetheless and it mostly
consists of machines beating humans at
their own games the famous example is
deep blue becoming superhuman on chess
and recently alphago beating lee sedol
and students probably dota 2 in
starcraft will be beat by open AI and
deep mine respectively but what we're
really interested in with k-lite in
building this competition is making
games that leverage both the best parts
of humans and the best parts of machines
we want to design games where humans
need to think through the strategies
think through the rules think through
the game logic and then design systems
that are executed by their BOTS
nicely yeah that you know I think that
there's often a conception of the
progress of AI as we're sort of
antagonistic to humans that it's like
well alright that's another thing that
machines are better at than humans when
Skynet coming but the we don't see it it
that way that there's there's no reason
that it has to be adversarial like that
that there one could easily imagine a
future in which you know humans and
machines coexist on the same games and
learn from them together in different
ways and we're excited by that prospect
so we're in a talk first very briefly
about some of the predecessors of halite
get into the Halo games and then talk
about the principles behind them so
diving in we start with the multi agent
programming contest which is a yearly
competition that's run since about 2005
and the the key contribution that this
really adds we think to the table is
this the multi agent aspect that when
you're controlling a bunch of different
agents at once the kinds of techniques
that one has to use are very different
than those when it's a single agent that
you know with a single agent a very
restricted number of actions it's
usually pretty easy to do pretty well
with something like Monte Carlo or
minimax methods and just some sort of
valuation function learned or hard-coded
but once the you explode the state space
with more more agents the the techniques
that one has to use become very
different and the multi agent program
contests really open that up yeah and
additionally these games are very hard
for humans to play in a vanilla fashion
like unless they write either heuristics
to have guide them through the game or
they write boxes BOTS as their executors
they are essentially unable to evaluate
who's winning the game and decide what
they should do and actually one last
point about the multi agent nature the
fact that it is hard for humans to play
is also a great motivator on the
educational aspect of these games but if
you're trying to encourage someone young
to get really interested in programming
and they're like what's the point it's
like why do I care having them see this
kind of a game that they you know can't
actually play effectively but looks into
and that they might want to play and
then showing them that there's a path to
this through computers is a really
effective teaching tool that's another
thing that comes out of this yes the
second predecessor to highlight is the
ARIMA challenge which is a derivative of
chess that's made explicitly hard for
game playing AI it's really impressive
since humans were actually the best
players of this game up until 2015 even
though the game is pretty simple the
state space is pretty small you're only
making one move per turn but still
evaluating the board is extremely hard
for computers and so we like to think
that we drew on both the tractability
and also the difficulty of ARIMA in
making halite the probably the most
direct spiritual predecessor of halite
is the you Waterloo and Google AI
challenge this is the ants competition
which was the third and final year of it
and what this did was it took these you
know previous multi-agent competitions
and it just completely opened them up to
the massive online scale that you know
now we have thousands of users that
whereas normally these you know older
programming contests we're like you're
on some mailing list they send it out
you think it's kind of cool you develop
it for a month and then you submit to
some conference and they rank them all
and that's you know some side list on
something or another now we can engage
with thousands of players and the an
important contribution is also the
real-time leaderboard from the AI
challenge and this is what enables it to
be an educational tool that extends
broadly beyond just a couple of
individual academics so that brings us
to finally even did iam which is the
last of our predecessors that won't
mention it also sort of ran concurrently
with halite one so there's those
elements of that too
and one of the really nice things about
Advent in iam you know even though it's
a single agent game and differs from
halia in a bunch of ways there's a lot
of core sort of infrastructure all
differences it's really nice visuals
that like you sort of see it and you're
like intrigued and you want to know
what's going on that the sprites moving
around it's very appealing so yeah and
we like to think that in making
we took something from all four of these
games from the multi-agent programming
competition we took the genre of
multi-agent games from ARIMA we took the
difficulty of the game from the AI
challenge we took the continuous global
leader board and from tvind inium we
took you know the visual appeal and
teammate and this leads in nicely to our
description of hail at 1 and hail 8 -
yeah so we'll start off with halite 1
which ran between 2016 and 2017 it had
about 1,600 users over the course of 3
months and will so we're gonna start
with the rules of it just to give a
general overview of them what you have
here are three different players on this
map this 2d grid and each one has the
objective of taking over the entire map
players are moving each individual piece
and up down left or right each turn are
telling it to remain still when they
remain still the pieces grow that you
can see that as the size of the square
increasing and when they interact with
opponents they fight and shrink so for
starters you'll just you'll immediately
notice this abstract design it's very
mathematical geometric in theming and in
fact the the only real connection has to
anything whatsoever as the name halite
that the name halite came from it sort
of looked like these cubic crystals
growing was one of the analogies that we
thought of but an important a couple of
important aspects of this that we have
the really simple rules and commands
that you just heard the all basically
all the rules there's not that much of
it you can easily explain it in well
under a paragraph and also the commands
that because you don't have you know
multiple types of units or anything
you're just telling your pieces where to
go it's really easy to get started a
side effect of this is you have a very
clean API for programming and you can
have a Python bought up in literally ten
lines of Python which is just it's nice
we also have the discrete grid space
this makes it very easy for beginners
because arrays are such a natural
programming tool to work with and
finally we have the emergent behaviors
of it then even though the rules are
simple there's a lot to do in this game
from working with the you know combat
optimization to deciding when you want
to grow your pieces or move them or
doing traffic control of all of your
pieces or deciding you know when you
want to expand your territory versus
attack your opponent's in conquer new
territory there's a whole bunch of
separate problems in this that all come
from these very simple rules and that's
what makes this game so unique and
interesting yeah and when we're
designing these games we like to say
that we want the players to play each
other and not to play the game and so
when you make the rules that simple when
you're not you know just making a
bloated game with a bunch of roadblocks
a bunch of you know constructed problems
for players to get through you leave
open the possibility of responding to
other players of having these nice
emergent behaviors and so this brings us
to a light to this ran last year it had
over 6,000 users and the game broadly
works like this you were the Admiral of
a fleet of ships every turn you look at
all of your ships and you set the
velocity of each of them in addition to
and so the ships exist within a
continuous space and movement in
addition to moving the ships can do two
things they can dock on planets and
planets produce more ships proportional
to the number of ships docked on the
planet and they can also fight other
ships so loosely when two ships are
within a certain radius they will
automatically attack each other and so
the game was in many ways a response to
halite one we wanted to try out some
different sorts of game design mechanics
and one of these is that it exists
within a continuous space of movement
and the advantage of this is that users
have more solutions that I can try out
combat code and navigation are actually
going to be more complex because of this
the drawback is that programmatically in
terms of the API it's more difficult
it's worse for beginners and so because
of this we actually are probably
reverting to a grid and halite 3 which
will come out in the fall we should
mention and you should go sign up at hey
Leo yes and also combat was much more
difficult in a light to inhale light
when it was very local it was if you
move a piece onto another they fight but
in halite 2 you had to do global
optimization to do combat properly
players actually called it flocking it's
when you have a group of ships stay
together and they single out lone
opponent ships they surround them and
they destroy the ship and then one
pretty obvious change between Haley one
and halite two is that now we have a
theme we're actually tying this to space
Wars and there are a couple of
advantages of that one it's probably
easier for you all looking at the two
games not knowing what they are to
understand what's happening in halite
two versus what's happening at halite
one you see ships you see planets you
see space and because of that we can
actually get away with some more complex
rules because when you think of actually
how physical movement works when you're
controlling a ship's velocity it's
mathematically pretty complicated but
humans understand how it works they come
into it with that intuition and we can
get away with a more interesting game
and then finally an important thing we
did with daylight two is we took away
AI programmers or deep learning
programmers only excuse for not writing
good BOTS that is we provided them GPUs
so on our servers they have basically
the compute they need to run whatever
gigantic convolutional neural networks
they want or DRL systems and we saw
players use that in very cool ways and
yeah so this brings us to a section on
how we're gonna describe loosely how we
design these games go over some
principles yes we'll start with the
principles so the first principle of
these games is they have to be simple
there's 10,000 things to do on the
internet why should you do halite even
if you should do halo and the games were
the rules were complicated it's really
hard for us to convince you to do halite
if you have to spend you know two hours
learning the ins and outs of some really
complicated set of rules so we took
inspiration from the game of go with
respect to this that you know it's such
an incredibly simple set of rules to
work with yet it's been incredibly
challenging and interesting for over you
know thousands of years we really want
to emulate something like that
another side effect the simplicity is
that you get a game which is fast to
compute which is usually advantageous
it's advantageous for a bunch of reasons
first we are running tens and millions
of games on our server fast to compute
lowers our cost which is nice it also
makes it easier for both developers that
when
they're you know testing locally and
working on their BOTS if they can run a
hundred games really quickly between
their own BOTS it makes it much easier
for them to iterate and we get better
more interesting submissions by the end
of the competition a second principle is
that these games need to be very visual
we like these you know sort of bright
colors on darkish backgrounds that pop
out you have the movement that kind of
catches your eye and draws you in and
this again connects back to both the
aspect of how are we going how we're
going to draw you in but also how are we
going to make you stay but when people
are developing their BOTS they're
usually watching hundreds of games over
the course and it may be thousands as
they're you know developing seeing other
people strategies and so on and if it's
not fun to watch you're not going to
want to participate so last it also
helps with the educational aspect it
makes it much you know especially
younger students seem to care a lot more
about this aspect that it's much more
helpful than drawing them in the game
needs to be difficult to solve it should
be evident that tic-tac-toe would not
make a great competition game because it
wouldn't last very long until someone
figured out the the dominant strategy
and in this way the V the games that we
work with need to not just be difficult
to solve but they also need to be I mean
they need to be you know beyond
impossible it's all set there's always a
lot of room at the top for something
with someone to do you don't want a sort
of asymptotic behavior of you're getting
really close to optimal the strategies
one of the ways that we achieve this in
part at least is by having the just a
like a an action space which is just
enormous that the number of you know
distinct move sets for a standard halite
position halite one was on the order of
ten to the 1,000th compare that with 300
or go not 10 to the 3x just 300 right
there's a lot its Monte Carlo is just
intractable when you have this sheer
number of so when the final sort of most
amorphous I love this animation the
final most amorphous element of the the
game that is that it needs to be
multi-dimensional there needs to be a
lot of different thing
to do in the game so that even if as a
developer you decide you know okay I've
done all that I can do with say the
combat optimization element at the end I
don't know what to do next if that's all
the rest of the game you'll get
frustrated and probably stop but we want
there you know to you just say oh but I
have the next thing to fir planet
selection is you know that's the next
thing I need to work on or ship
navigation or you know who knows what
but as long as there's at least five or
six things to work with
it makes it more interesting at the
upper level then you've got
differentiation between the top players
so some bots are good at different
different kinds of things and also makes
it better for the even a new developer
that there's just something for them to
always do so how do we design these game
so well the first thing that we want to
focus on is the fact that it's really
largely iterative we don't know how to
make these games right the first time
most games will satisfy one or two of
our requirements but very few of them
three or four and almost no games
satisfy everything that we want what you
see on the left is the oldest image I
have from my laptop of halite one
development and then on the right the
actual finished halite one game and what
I hope you see are both the similarities
between them the grid like space and the
sort of blob ish expansion with spaces
between but also the difference is that
there's you know the size the map is
very different the rules internally
which you can't see are different and
there's your two or three separate games
that get us from the one on the left to
the right the next thing we really try
to take to heart in cutting down these
games once we've decided on a base set
of rules is we try to the best of our
ability to reduce the number of unit
types and constants in the game so when
you just by definition have a lot of
unit types in your game the length of
your rules is going to be huge you don't
you know players are going to have to
memorize a tech tree or the abilities of
the soldier class versus the worker
class etc and that's fine
and it appeals to a certain demographic
but for example a mount MIT battlecode
has for a decade plus released games to
take advantage of this unit type
classing too much success
and their demographic really loves it
you know they enjoys scouring through
long page specs trying to find that one
hole in the balancing so that they can
you know write the dominant strategy but
that's just not what we're trying to do
with daylight we want halite to be
broadly applicable to all programmers on
the internet we want them to be able to
write a bot after two minutes of looking
at our API and looking at our game rules
and so we really try and reduce that
this also I think ties into the theme of
having players play against each other
rather than against the game that we
sort of feel that you know when it's
about reading through the spec and
trying to just understand what the game
is and how to you know best use the the
flaws or you know balancing of the game
then we really feel like you're much
more so playing against the game than
you are against the other players that
the games are much more interesting when
you're looking at how players interact
with each other which we'll see a little
bit later on our game theory section and
we just we you know the game is really
just a medium for players to actually
interact and learn from each other right
yeah that brings us to the point of
emergent behaviors this really is just a
natural thing that comes from the fact
that we require the games to be simple
difficult to solve and multi-dimensional
so it's difficult to solve and
multi-dimensional basically means that
you have to have lots of distinct
complex behaviors that come out of it
but yet because it's simple we can't
write lots of complex rules so the only
solution to this is that we have simple
rules and from those simple rules emerge
these complex behaviors what we have
here that what you're seeing is a
Conway's Game of Life a certain starting
state and Conway's for those who don't
know Conway's Game of Life is a cellular
automata which basically means that the
state of each cell depends only on the
state of its neighbors and there's the
rules can be described in like three
bullet points it's incredibly simple but
from these simple rules come all these
complicated behaviors that you have you
know on the left you see what are called
a glider guns which are producing this
infinite stream of buyers and then this
whole contraption is a cut something
called a breeder which Bruce an infinite
stream of these glider guns people have
even constructed entire Turing machines
in
converse game of life which shows you
just the level of complexity associated
with it um so we were really inspired by
that we wanted to replicate that kind of
emergence with Haley walk but there's a
second side of this point which is that
when the behaviors that you're trying to
design are emergent by definition you
can't understand them just by breaking
it down to the constituent pieces so as
far as we know the only solution to this
is playtesting that we make the games
and we see what are the kinds of things
that we expect to be effective are and
the things that shouldn't be aren't and
make that all work if anyone knows a
better way of doing this please come see
me after the talk finishes I would I
would love to know so that will take us
finally to target statistics yeah this
is I think just more of a sub point of
this that often with these games when
we're trying you know we have most of
the game figured out we want to just
tune certain parameters of it make it as
interesting as possible
well sometimes also collect statistics
that can be used to better understand
the game so what you're seeing right
here we've co-opted from the you know
fields I've been economics the Gini
coefficient which is a statistical
measure of inequality you've applied it
to halite maps to try to figure out how
production on halide maps is distributed
so if this we're allowed us to produce
this distribution that basically shows
us that you know most maps have roughly
this level of distribution of production
through them but that there's also this
kind of variance and this is just this
is a good kind of distribution because
it shows that for a beginner you can
mostly ignore the outside of that
distribution you can say most games I'm
gonna be playing roughly work with this
kind of map this rough level of you know
distribution but that also there's you
know on the outside there's lots of
different variety of maps that happen
less frequently and that makes for some
really interesting games every once in a
while so that allows us to help verify
that the games that we're making really
are interesting yeah so now we're gonna
to clecos uh-huh
so now we're gonna talk you know in
broad categories about the solutions
that the interesting solutions that our
contestants made for halite one in
halite two I think this is a good
point to mention that Ben and I we think
that AI compasses a lot more than deep
learning there are a lot more
interesting techniques such as heuristic
based models and using game theory to
solve the sorts of problems that deep
learning is using learning deep learning
is trying to solve right we love deep
learning we you know there's a lot of
amazing research that's come out
recently in it
we just think you know tool in the
toolbox a lot of our users are very
inexperienced at programming a you know
the vast majority of em have under three
years of experience so we have to make
sure that we support all sorts of
different users not just those that are
interested in deep learning yeah and so
the most prevalent category of solutions
to hey let one in hey lie to is just
simply the heuristic bot and all that a
heuristic bot is is it's just hand coded
logic hand coded strategies for playing
the games of Halo at one in halite too
and so one example of a heuristic is
just go to the highest production zone
which is actually shown here so the
production that been referenced before
when talking about the map Gini
coefficient is shown by I don't know how
well you can see it here but it's the
back shading on this visualizer so you
see that the area that this yellow
player is going to is a high production
zone and so at the start of the game of
a light it tunnels to that zone and then
starts to expand so it can get a jump on
its production rates and heuristic bots
are interesting to us for two reasons
one the really democratic they're really
simple you know anybody with moderate
programming skills can write these BOTS
it's just simple logic and then the
second point is and requires humans to
actually think through the strategy and
it's really in line with our human plus
machine way of constructing games when
you use something like Monte Carlo trees
that are generally generally applicable
to all games
you're not thinking through the
specifics of that game you're just you
know applying that hammer that tool in
the toolbox to the game and the same is
true for deep learning
but with heuristics box you you really
are combining the power of humans and
the power of machines it's also I think
ties into the educational aspect of it
that by forcing you to think through the
the game and you know your logic and
what the effects of your logic will be
on how your bot plays the game we think
this is a really important step in
teaching lots of younger programmers how
to get better that you know this ability
to
really visually see how your changes
affect your bought and the behavior is
an incredibly valuable tool in learning
to do do so even more effectively yeah
and then this is a more complicated
heuristic sema4 halite - so we aren't
going to go into too much detail but
this was from a top 100 player in the
competition and broadly what he did is
every turn he computed a gradient which
is shown here in 3d with the hills and
the valleys and what he did for each of
his chips is he looked at the gradient
and he had the ship go in a direction
that a ball bearing would go if it was
just rolling down these hills right and
the whole strategy of this schema is
encoded in a few set of parameters and
these parameters are just how much in
terms of downhill miss or uphill Ness
various game objects will affect the
gradient so for example you want to stay
away a little bit from your own ships
your friendly ships and halite - because
if you collide with your own ships
they're eliminated right and so they'll
have a bit of an uphill effect on the
gradient we do have lots of players that
do utilize machine learning and deep
learning so what you see here is a
diagram of a CNN that was used to play
halite one to great effects this was
from user J sneaker 7 so you know
certain kinds of deep learning methods
don't work particularly well with halite
namely the sort of alphago styled Monte
Carlo methods because the space is so
large but lots of them do in this case
this was simply trained on the moves of
the top a couple of users and got
handily into the top 20 of the
competition out of thousands of players
so that's pretty good we think we've
also had players used reinforcement
learning and policy gradients on sort of
parametrized non deep models that's also
been used to a pretty good effect top
100 yeah and we are excited for what's
going to continue to happen especially
with halite 3 didn't want to say too
much except that we think that there's a
lot of promise we've been exploring it
personally for what can be done with
halite 3 and the deep learning space so
and then finally finally one of the nice
things about halite is that since we try
and build in this multidimensionality
there is both the element of local
you know at the peace level and also
there is definitely an important level
of meta game of meta play and so we saw
this inhale at one actually at the end
of the competition a very important
emergent behavior in the meta game was
something called the non-aggression pact
and it was basically just an implicit
alliance between every player in a game
if you enter the alliance they fought
the logic that you encode in your bot is
that you won't attack any other player
until they've attacked you and so say if
five out of the six players in a game
put this logic in their bought that last
six player is going to be attacked by
all five first and so because of this
all the players at the top of our
leaderboard in the last few days of the
game encoded this logic and they're
bought it really exploded that it was
like very unexpected by us like he is
just a huge shift in the rankings in the
last couple of days especially including
their our very top user who probably was
substance significantly influenced by
his incredibly effective handling of
this whole meta game yes yeah so and
finally we're gonna talk about our
competition principle yeah this is
actually these are the principles we
take to heart when we're building the
competition around the halite games so
stuff like our learning resources our
website our forums our tooling etc and
so the most important of these
principles is that they need to be very
beginner friendly but also powerful
so like Ben said earlier you know we're
dealing with people on the Internet they
have you know minute long attention
spans they need to be interested by
halite after you know just reading the
game rules for a paragraph and looking
at our tooling right and so one way in
which we make it very frictionless to
onboard people is we support 20 plus
languages most of these are contributed
by the community but that means that you
know if you're a beginner and you like
Python you can jump into the game but
also if you're you know a rust
enthusiast you don't have to deal with
you know the annoyance of Java but we
also we take this to heart with our
other resources for halite 3 we're
working on a web IDE for users who are
not competent in the command line and
also some more interactive tutorial
experiences and then the second thing we
take to heart is the competition is
really real-time to its core
so we've already mentioned the
continuous leaderboard that is central
to Haley it works and we've heard from
users that that is one of the best
things about the competition for example
that third user you see there Shami is a
very enthusiastic Allstate actuary who
submitted 600 baud updates to the
competition and our meeting level of bot
submission was very high I think it was
like something around twenty something
for halite one was the median level
so yeah the the leaderboard got a lot of
use because you can make just a small
change to your BOTS submit it and within
a couple of minutes you're seeing that
you bought playing games against
everybody else on the leaderboard it's
very immediate feedback and then we also
need to build an in collaborative spaces
for users online because often other
BOTS developers can help users better
than we can help them because they've
actually had you know the annoyances the
frustrations the joys of working on
halite and we're coming into it with
like a lot of existing knowledge about
the competition just we built it and so
one way in which we do this is we have a
discourse forum with some nice gaming
shown here this saw a lot of use you
know 100 reply long threads about
everything from bought strategies to bug
reports to you know tools new tools that
the community has developed somebody
developed a third party user developed a
very popular visualizer for halite -
that's all a lot of use on the forums
and the second thing we do is we also
have a discord chat that lots of players
used and then finally what we're dealing
with on the backend of halite which yeah
we haven't really touched on a lot in
this presentation for about you is a
kind of a hard engineering problem
because we are for halite - we had about
six point five hundred users and we need
to rank all of these users very quickly
and so we run tens of millions of games
of halite on our back end to rank all
these users over the lifetime of the
competition and so this is hard for two
reasons one
we're running untrusted user code on our
servers so security is a big problem and
then also this needs to be scalable you
know we're going from running no games
at the start of the competition to many
millions of games in a week at the end
of the competition so we need our
infrastructure scale up seamlessly and
so Jack our lead engineer is here to
talk about that
oh hi sorry so as Ben and Michael said
it is a very very difficult problem to
solve and for a very very difficult
problem we require good architecture so
that's how we use Google so Google has
in this way actually granted us the
ability to solve all of these problems
in a very simple way almost
plug-and-play and so right now I'm gonna
walk you through all the problems all
the challenges that we had and how we
solved them and how Google actually
helped us solve them
first of all games are ripe with
cheating the greater the competition the
greater the want for users to cheat and
we store quite a large number of
personally identifiable information here
including user emails among other things
and those two factors mean we need a lot
of security to ensure malicious
activities at a minimum and of course we
also run a large large amount of
arbitrary code as was mentioned we have
6,000 users with the total of over
50,000 BOTS submitted in over 25
languages and you know lots of
frameworks and that's a lot of untrusted
code and as I said a lot of personal
identifiable information and all of that
adds to the problem secondly variable
ranking algorithms need to play a lot of
games before fair convergence and
especially if there's a lot of users
this increases exponentially which
requires much more compute in many more
games and with the time and the outcome
of this is either general frustration
for users or large cost of the
administrators and many times both
regionality is also a big problem a
competition encompassing over a hundred
countries worldwide creates some
complexity explicitly how do we provide
equally fast responses to players all
over the globe though we don't require
sub-millisecond responses like a lot of
multiplayer games require we still need
to think of some expediency otherwise
users will be upset reliability is a
very common problem but it's a problem
nonetheless how do you make sure the
disturbances are
users generally shy away from anything
especially games they can't access and
it doesn't matter how fun you make a
game if you can't play it no one's going
to play it so for that we need to
minimize a downtime ai is another well
quote-unquote problem that we want to
solve gonna make this game amenable to
AI and for games to be fairly solvable
we need to provide both data and tools
related to the problem and especially as
the data increases which in our case
includes megabyte replays from over 25
million games which you can see is a lot
the problem becomes increasingly more
difficult so how do we solve them we
have two types of solutions that we have
here ones that we technically got for
free by using Google and ones that we
had to build in-house so I'm going to
separate them in all the solutions first
off in terms of security through GCP we
got good containerization so we didn't
have to worry about that we managed to
close all internet routes going outside
of all our machines that were running
untrusted code so people couldn't do bad
things like say Bitcoin mining in our
machines we we placed a good number of
firewalls to make sure people just
weren't doing bad things and talking to
machines they weren't supposed to be
talking to we created a large amount of
database in GCS isolation so that only
some machines could talk to them and of
course you use the grade 3 PC service
controls that are used widely that
really allow us to just talk to the
machines that we want to talk and not
having it and have any indirectness
towards that and of course in our
in-house solutions we had a vast number
of system level defenses including
cgroups IP tables among other things
that allows us to really isolate
everything we had bought a normalization
so if you're playing you didn't really
know what the other BOTS were sit
couldn't exploit anything related to
that and we created score penalties like
everything else I mean we can you can
think of that as really an AI problem as
people do malicious things you penalize
them and they stop doing malicious
things so it's a type of reinforcement
learning that we gave our users so for
sport convergence in GCP we had auto
scaling groups which were great because
suddenly based on number of users just
automatically became bigger or smaller
and of course that lowered the cost and
what lower de costs even more
significantly are preemptable
preemptable was made it insanely cheap
for us to run a lot of things and get
very quick convergence in house we had
effective scoring algorithms who used
the best of the best to make sure it was
fast and we tuned it to the best of our
abilities to make sure it was really
fast in terms of regionality this was
whole and Google thankfully a reliable
regionality toggle switch is one of
their best feature it's so we didn't
really just use that and put
plug-and-play caching and CD ends for
website and data respectively
significantly simplify the problem
Google has its famous many nines which
you can see based on even the room you
have here to five nines room which makes
the service portion of this a non
problem however the use of preemptable
adds a further complexity machines now
can and will go down at any point making
a quad redundant more specifically
duplicating executions and services
saving results doing backups using
health checks automatic restarts
recreates and leveraging fault tolerant
algorithms is not a new solution but
it's the key to reliability the solution
of course translates beyond preemptable
and ensures that even on a rather faulty
execution Byzantine failures you'll be
resilient ultimately Google is very very
old gear to solving AI problems as you
may have heard in other sessions that's
what they're amazing at by utilizing
very powerful GPUs and storing
everything in GCS we significantly
improve the process for all the users
for everything else who wrote a number
of training tools in Python to simplify
the process in both interacting with GCP
and halide directly which ultimately
gives us this picture which which gives
us this picture which is specifically
what our end picture was we had CDN
serving all of the important data inside
of our V PC which was well protected as
I mentioned we had three types of
machines all done by managed instance
groups that grew or decrease as required
in this sense we had the website which
literally just served the website we had
coordinators which were the key API and
managed to send games for the workers to
play the workers could only talk to the
coordinators meanwhile the coordinators
were the liaison the mediator in between
GCS and cloud sequel where we really
stored all that we needed to store and
through that we got our complete picture
and now for why halite by bringing back
to LC all right so why again do we care
about halite let's go back to what Ben
was saying about games role in in
playing and learning right we learned
through play but competitions also
provide an opportunity to learn from
each other they're not just about
winning they allow us to educate each
other through play any age any
experience level in halite we've heard
examples of how players learned by
example of other BOTS there were trends
in different strategies players also
contributed tutorials and bought
post-mortems to share what they had
learned and also express their
creativity by finding new opportunities
for new ways to play with Haley for
example writing their names with their
BOTS technology really enables this
connectivity and a successful execs
successful competition but you know we
see connectivity all over the place
including in say MOOCs which have forums
and tutorials along with guided lessons
we think looped MOOCs are not adaptive
or computationally intensive so they're
not really taking advantage of what
technology has to offer for learning
today our goal with Haley is really to
explain exploit that possibility so
games and global programming challenges
running in the cloud are immersive
they're open-ended with potential for
any number of create
strategies as we've heard and they're
adaptive so they're suited to beginners
who may just be looking to gain
confidence in their first programming
language but also provide the
opportunity for more experienced players
to gain mastery of a particular skillset
really this is about engaging with
skills and and tools on your own terms
so if we revisit this question of how
humans and machines can work together
let's go back to Ben and Michael saying
that you halide is really about humans
working with machines not competing
against the machine we've seen at this
conference the increasing number of ways
in which humans and machines are being
paired together or have to pair together
to solve problems in the real world and
the real world as we know is highly
uncertain and requires flexible and
adaptive solutions so our question is to
what extent can games and collaborative
programming challenges like halite
actually serve as a training ground for
training in telling and building
intelligent machines so playing a game
it's not just about winning it's also
about it's also about thinking through
which we learn and with these games we
see there's no one path to learn there's
no path one path to learning and at the
same time there may be we may have goals
and specific skills that we'd want to
acquire but those skills have many
applications so at two sigma we we take
learning and education very seriously we
take problem-solving very seriously and
what we ask you to think about is you
know what are the ways to really be
engaged in your learning we think halite
the global AI competition serves a
unique educational function with a lot
of opportunity we'd love to hear your
feedback as Ben and Michael mentioned
we're launching halite through this fall
and you can sign up but in advance of
the competition we'd also like to design
it to make sure that you can achieve
your
goals so thank you very much
[Music]